ein hoch auf den Kommunismus äh wie
warum das ist offenbar das besser
politische System wenn man lediglich die
Fakten vergleicht ui ui was sagt der
denn da das darf man doch noch nicht mal
denken in Deutschland ist nämlich der
alljährliche Bericht des Experten Rates
für Klimafragen veröffentlicht worden
und der hat der Bundesregierung mal
wieder ein schlechtes Zeugnis
ausgestellt die Gurkentruppe hat es
schon wieder versemmelt Klimaziele
verfehlt 6 setzen die machen nicht nur
schlechte Klimapolitik sondern die ist
sogar so schlecht dass sie
verfassungsfeindlich ist denn die
Klimaneutralität bis 2045 ist inzwischen
aufgrund eines Hotels des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts Teil des
Grundgesetzes spricht hier werden
eklatant die Menschenrechte verletzt und
da beschweren wir uns noch über das
kommunistische China die machen es uns
nämlich vor die erreichen nicht nur ihre
Klimaziele die sind sogar früher am Ziel
zehn Jahre zumindest was das betrifft
ist der Kommunismus also
menschenfreundlicher vielleicht hätten
wir die kommunistische Parteien 1956
lieber doch nicht verboten dann wird es
uns heute vielleicht besser gehen